بدا رئيس وزراء تركيا بن علي الدرم زياره
للعراق التي التقى خلالها نظيره العراقي
حيدر العبادي الذي اعلن من جانبه الاتفاق
على سحب القوات التركيه من معسكر بعشيقه
بينما اشار يلدرم الى ان ذلك سيحدث عندما
تستقر الامور في
العراق
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما هي حدود التوافق و وماذا بقي من
الخلاف بين انقره وبغداد حول وجود قوات
تركيه في بعشيقه وما هي افاق تطور
العلاقات بين الجانبين وتاثير ذلك على
ازمات
[موسيقى]
المنطقه بعد عامين من الغياب يصل الى
بغداد مسؤول تركي في بمستوى رئيس الوزراء
بن علي الدرم لكن بغداد ليست المحطه
الوحيده في هذه الزياره اربيل ايضا على
جدول الاعمال وحصله لقاءات الرجل في بغداد
تشي برغبه طرفين في طي صفحه الخلافات وان
كانت تدل على تلاشيها بالكامل تبقى مساله
وجود القوات التركيه في بعشيقه عقبه على
الطريق لكن تبدو في المقابل مسائل اخرى
مثل تعاون الاقتصادي محفزات للمضي قدما في
مسار من التوازنات
يحرص عليها الطرفان ما الذي يدفع الطرفين
لهذا التقرب المحسوب وما الذي يصعب من
حقيق تحقيقه اسئله نناقشها بعد تقرير مريم
ابيش رئيس الوزراء التركي بن علي يلدرم في
ضيافه بغداد اول زياره لمسؤول بهذا الثقل
للعراق منذ
عامين خلف حفاوه الاستقبال والابتسامات
امام الكاميرات خلافات وملفات عال وحرب
تصريحات سابقه وايضا استدعاء للسفراء في
مرحله التصعيد هل ستطوى هذه الزياره
المهمه في توقيتها واهدافها صفحه الماضي
وتؤسس لعلاقات افضل بين بغداد وانقره لهجه
التصريحات الان هادئه ولكنها لم تصل حد
التناغم بعد فيما يتعلق بتواجد القوات
التركيه في بعشيقه تم الاتفاق على صيغه في
البيان الختامي بين الطرف العراقي يطلب
انسحاب القوات التركيه من الاراضي
العراقيه في بعشيقه والطرف التركي اكد
التزامه بالسياده العراقيه وبوح الاراضي
العراقيه في هذا الاطار سياده العراق
ووحدته مساله حساسه بالنسبه لنا وحين يتم
احلال السلام في المنطقه هو يكون كل شيء
على ما يرام سيتم الانسحاب وهذا واضح جدا
غير واضح تماما احتمال التوصل الى جدول
زمني لانسحاب القوات التركيه من بلده
بعشيقه كما طلبت وكانت بغداد ارسلت انقره
نحو 500 جندي الى البلده القريبه من
الموصل في اطار الحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وما تسميه خط الدفاع الاول
للجمهوريه وهو الخط الواصل بين الموصل
وحلب امر اعتبرته بغداد انتهاكا صارخا
لسيادتها وتدخلا غير مقبول انقره تطالب من
جهتها الحكومه العراقيه بطرد مقاتلي حزب
العمال الكردستاني ليس هذا المطلب الوحيد
للجاره التركيه فهي تحذر من تغيير
ديمغرافيا تلعفر على يد ميليشيات مسلحه
تنفذ الاجنده الايرانيه ذهب البعض واكثر
من مره الى وصف التباعد التركي العراقي
بانه واجهه لخلاف تركي ايراني هل التقارب
اليوم ممكن ومقابل ماذا اهوى موسم التصالح
من اجل حمايه المصالح التركيه في الداخل
والخارج بعد روسيا والعراق واتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار في سوريا من ستكون التاليه في
قائمه دبلوماسيه التهدئه الاخيره بين
بغداد وانقره نهيك عن ملف مكافحه تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه هناك ايضا التعاون
الاقتصادي واحتمال بيع الغاز العراقي
لاوروبا عن طريق ميناء جيهان التركي
ومساله فتح معبر حدودي جديد بينهما اضافه
الى معبر ابراهيم الخليل مياه الدجله
والفرات لا تقل اهميه عن القضايا الاخرى
يبدو ان زمن التصريحات الناريه من قبيل
الزم حدودك التي قالها اردوغان للعباد
سابقا قد انتهت اليوم عهد جديد وسنه جديده
في علاقات بين جارتين ما يجمعهما نظريا
اكثر مما
يفرق موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيفنا
في بغداد الدكتور احسان الشمري رئيس مركز
التفكير السياسي وينضم الينا ايضا من
انقره محي الدين اتمان الباحث في مركز
الدراسات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
سيتا سيد اتمان بين عباره الزم حدودك التي
اطلقها اردوغان في وجه العبادي منذ فتره
قصيره وبين هذا الدف الذي تجسده زياره
يلدرم الى بغداد كيف امكن ردم هذه الهوه
بهذه السرعه وبهذه
السلاسه في
الواقع ان العلاقه بين تركيا
والعراق لم تكن تخاصم و متشدده الخصومه
لكن بعض العناصر او الاسباب التي ادت الى
توتر بين البلدين ونعرف ان اكثر التوتر
كان بسبب معسكر بعشيقه وفي ذلك الوقت انا
كنت في مقابله على شبكه الجزيره ايضا وقلت
بان هذه ليست ازمه عراقيه بل هذه هذه ازمه
امريكا وايران والان نرى
وبتغير الموقف في الشرق الاوسط ان الحكومه
العراقيه حكومه العبادي بدات تسير على
سياسه خارجيه اكثر استقلاليه ازاء القضايا
الاقليميه ومنها ازاء تركيا ولذلك من جانب
اخر نجد ان تركيا ايضا غيرت جوانب من
سياستها الخارجيه في المنطقه اذ انها بدات
بالاقتراب من موسكو وبدات تطبيع العلاقات
مع دوله اسرائيل وبالتالي فان تركيا تريد
زياده العلاقات ما بين الحكومات في
المنطقه ولهذا السبب نجد ان تركيا تحاول
ان تحل كل النزاعات بين البلدين او كل
الخلافات ونعلم ان هناك اعتماد متبادل
كبير بين العراق وتركيا وبالتالي فان رغم
انه كانت هناك بعض الخلافات السياسيه فال
له على الجانب الاقتصادي كانت علاقات جيده
جدا طيب اسمح لي سيده
تمان سيده تمان بعد اذنك يعني سانتقل الى
الدكتور الشمري لاسال الدكتور يعني هل هو
تقارب فعلي هل هي فعلا مؤشرات تقارب فعلي
بين البلدين باتجاه ربما الالتقاء عند
ارضيه سياسيه واحده ام انه تغليب للمصالح
المشتركه مع القبول ب
الافكار والمواقف والقناعات على
حالها شكرا على الاستضافه يعني ما يؤشر
لهذه الزياره انها
طيت من خلالها صفحه الماضي
وبالتالي عملت على ايجاد مساحه مشتركه ما
بين الطرفين تركيا تراجعت كثيرا امام
الثبات العراق الذي تمثل بموقف رئيس
الوزراء الدكتور حيدر العبادي وقضيه تواجد
القوات تركيا وانتهاك اهل السياده
العراقيه واضف الى ذلك طبيعه الدعم الكبير
من قبل المنظومه العربيه المنظومه
الاقليميه وحتى الدوليه زء هذا الموضوع
انا بتصوري جعل تركيا تراجع الكثير من
حساباتها ليس من مصلحه تركيا ان تخسر
العراق الان الذي يخوض حربا ضد الارهاب
وبمساندة
من الاستمرار
بمساحه المختلف ما بين انقره وبغداد لذلك
وجدت بان يعني اعاده فتح الملفات وبما
ينمي العلاقات من جديد على اساس المصالح
المشتركه وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
خير ما يمكن ان يدفع بموقف تركيا ليس فقط
اتجاه العراق وانما حتى رساله الى بقيه
الدول الاخرى انا اعتقد ان هذه الزياره س
تفتح افاق جديده على كافه المستويات يعني
ليس اقلها سحب القوات التركيه وهذا ما صدر
في البيان المشترك وهو نزول بكل الاحوال
لرغبه العراق ورغبه رئيس الوزراء الدكتور
حيدر العبادي في ضروره الحفاظ على سياده
العراق انا اعتقد ان هذه الخ نعم هذه
الزياره لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
نصفها في اطار العموميات بقدر ما ان هناك
رغبه من قبل تركيا تركيا اللام بحاجه ماسه
الى العراق في كافه الصعد لا اتحدث فقط عن
قضيه الجانب السياسي والاقتصادي بل حتى
الامني تركيا تعرضت لارهاب وا استهدافات
من قبل الارهاب ولذلك هي تعمل
على توظيف الخبره العراقيه فيما يرتبط
بالمعلوم اشرت اشرت الى الملف العالق في
الحقيقه والذي يكتسب اكثر حساسيه في
العلاقات بين البلدين وهو التواجد التركي
في معسكر بعشيقه سيد اتمان
يلدرم قال نعم نعم على مستوى المبدا نحن
قابلون بهذا الانسحاب ولكن بعد ان يكون كل
شيء على ما يرى ماذا يعني او متى سيكون كل
شيء على ما يرام وما هو هذه وما هي هذه
الاشياء
اصلا
اوكي اولا
اود ان اقول بان
تركيا اعلنت ومر اخرى عن احترامها للسياده
الاقليميه والسياده الوطنيه العراقيه وان
تركيا موجوده في بعشيقه ليس كتدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه لدوله العراق بل لمواجهه
وتحدي طرفين غير حكوميين منظمتين ارهابيين
مع مع الاسف تقومان بالهجوم على تركيا من
الاراضي العراقيه احدها حزب العمال
الكردستاني والاخر داعش كما تعلمون وان
حكومه العراق ولسوء الحظ غير قادره على
منع استخدام اراضيها ضد تركيا وبالتالي
فان تركيا اولا وقبل كل شيء موجوده في
بعشيقه للسيطره
ولمواجهه مساله مواجهتها لهاتين المنظمتين
وان نعلم ان تركيا تود
ان تساهم في تحقيق الامن لدوله العراق
ايضا وفي حربها ضد داعش اثناء عمليه تحرير
الموصل وبالتالي لحد الان لا نعرف هذا
الامر سيستمر لاي مده الامر يعتمد على
الطورات المستقبليه ولكن تركيا ليست في
بعشيقه لتبقى هناك الى
الابد وما
ان تنتهي المخاطر ضد الامن الوطني التركي
و نخلص منها فان ان هذه القوه الصغيره
التركيه سوف تنسحب من الاراضي العراقيه
دكتور شمري بما ان القاعده هنا هي يعني
اخذ وعطاء ايضا لانقره مطالب مطلبها الهام
والرئيسي هو ان لا تسمح بغداد من هنا
فصاعدا بان تكون حاضنه لمقاتلي حزب العمال
الكردستاني كيف يمكن لبغداد ان تفي ايضا
بهذا
الالتزام
الحكومه
العراقيه الحاليه غير مسؤوله عن تواجد
البككا سبق وان تم عقد اتفاق ما بين انقره
وما بين حزب العمال الكردستاني وهو من دفع
هذه المنظمه الى على مستوى الشريط الحدودي
ما بين تركيا
والعراق وحتى وصلوا الى جبال القنديل هذا
اولا لكن اختلف مع
ضيفك التركي بالتحديد بان الحكومه
العراقيه غير قادره انا ا كد بان الحكومه
العراقيه قادره يعني على مستوى الاراده او
حتى على مستوى النصوص الدستوريه لا يوجد
يعني ذلك الغطاء الدستوري و فيما يرتبط
بتواجد اي من المنظمات التي يمكن ان تهدد
دول الجوار وال رئيس الوزراء العراقي
اعلنها صراحه بانه لن يسمح بمثل هكذا
تواجد او ما يمكن
ان يدفع باتجاه تهديد الامن القومي لتركيا
او حتى دول الجوار سواء كان جوارا عربيا
او اقليميا
لذلك الموضوع انا اعتقد انه يرفع الغطاء
او حتى المبرر من المخاوف التركيه الان
البككا هي تتواجد اصلا في الداخل التركي
يعني كثير من العمليات التي حدثت على
مستوى التفجيرات حدثت من الداخل التركي لا
لم يكن للعراق يدم فيها او لم يكن العراق
هو مصدر انطلاق هذه الجماعات وهذا امر
معروف لذ لذلك انا اعتقد ان هذا المبرر
يعني لا يمكن ان يكون مسوغا لبقاء القوات
التركيه
المشترك صراحه حتى نمر الى الى جوانب اخرى
وزوايا اخرى في هذه العلاقه فقط نتوقف عند
فاصل قصير بعد نناقش افاق تطور العلاقات
بين بغداد وانقره وتاثيراتها على ملفات
المنطقه نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش
دوافع والافاق التي تفتحها زياره رئيس
الوزراء التركي بن علي الدريم الى العراق
سيد اتمان هل نتحدث عن تحسن في العلاقات
الثنائيه ام ان هذا التحسن
سيتداخل الزياره هي زياره
تاريخيه وانها ستؤدي الى تحسين العلاقات
بين
البلدين اولا ان هذه
الزياره هي
مبادره اساسيه
للحوار تحقيق الحوار السياسي وبناء الثقه
المتبادله بين البلدين والشيء الثاني هنا
هو ان البلدين قد
قررا قررا ان يسعيان
يحاربان المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي تدعمت
تقوم ممارسه العنف ومن المهم ان نلاحظ
انه ان العراق وتركيا هما بلدان
رئيسيان في ضمن الهلال
الخصيب في قلب منطقه الشرق الاوسط والشيء
الاخر المهين الذي يحترمه البلدان هو
السلامه الاقليميه لبلدين وانهما لن يسمحا
باي منظمات بالعمل بالتحرك بحريه داخل
بلديهما وعندما تجتمع وتتفق تركيا والعراق
فان مما لا شك في ان ذلك سيساهم في تحقيق
الاستقرار في
سوريا ذلك ان الحدود بين سوريا والعراق
والحدود بين هذا تركيا فهذا الحد بين هذه
الدول الثلاثه مهمه جدا فدما هذه الدول
الثلاثه حاليا لكن حاليا في سوريا يسنا
حكومه او هيكل جيد للحكومه وبالتالي
يبقى يبقى على التركيا والعراق ضمان امن
الحدود والنقطه
الاخرى هو ان ذلك سوف دي ايضا الى تحقيق
توازن بين ايران ودول الخليج وتركيا
وبالتالي فان موقع الدوله العراق موقع في
غايه اهميه من اجل استقرار المنطقه سيد
الشمري طبيعي ان هذه المصالحه ربما لم
تاتي من من عدم وهنا اسال عن دور الاطراف
الاخرى في تسهيل هذه المصالحه وباي عين
تنظر الى هذه المصالحه خاصه ايران
والاجنحه اليمينيه الموجوده في في الحكم
داخل بغداد
لا يوجد قلق يعني داخلي على اقل تقدير
الداخل العراقي يعني ينظر الى هذه الزياره
على انه على انها عفوا حققت الكثير على
مستوى السياده العراقيه يعني حتى الاطراف
التي اشرت اليها هي تتبع بكل الاحوال
الراي العام الرسمي العراقي ايران لم تصدر
بيانا على مستوى تواجد القوات التركيه الا
متاخره جدا ولذلك ال يعني كل ما جرى على
مستوى العلاقات يعني من توتر او حتى تقارب
حالي وتصالح واذابه لجلد الخلافات هو بحكم
الفاعل العراقي الداخلي لا يوجد مخاوف
العراق لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
يمضي
بالانخراط
باي من المحاور المتصارعه على مستوى
المنطقه هو يضع في حساب المصلحه العراقيه
حتى الاطراف الداخليه الان هناك ترحيب
كبير في هذه الزياره وما نتجت عنه وما
اتفق عليه ولكن داخل الائتلاف الحاكم داخل
الائتلاف العراقي الحاكم سيد الشمري يعني
واضح انه لا يوجد تناغم كبير ولا يوجد
التقاء كلي حول
يعني الوجهات التي يمكن ان تاخذها
الدبلوماسيه العراقيه والعلاقات العراقيه
الخارجيه وهناك تخوفات فعلا من
يدخل طرف اخر من داخل الائتلاف على هذه
العلاقه في محاوله ربما لتخريب او لاضعاف
مجددا الى حد هذه اللحظه يعني حتى اكون
واضح لم يصدر اي شيء من اي من الاطراف
العراقيه السياسيه داخل منظومه التحالف
الوطني الشيعيه وهذا اولا الامر الاخر
السياسه الخارجيه يقررها تقررها الحكومه
وايضا من يضع السياسات العامه هو رئيس
الوزراء العراقي ولا يوجد هناك اي اعتراض
يعني زاء التجه الى تركيا على العكس هناك
علاقات استراتيجيه بعيده قد لا تكون
منظوره ما بين انقره من جهه وطهران من جهه
اخرى نحن نبحث عن المصلحه العراقيه وبما
يحفظ السياده اما الاراء الاخرى فانا
اعتقد انه لا يمكن الاخذ بها الاهم هو ما
تنظر اليه الحكومه العراقيه الى ما يمكن
ان تستجيب هذه اللقاءات من مصلحه و
مردودات ايجابيه بالنسبه للمصالح وسياده
العراقيه وهذا الاهم من وجهه نظري طيب سيد
اتمان هذه المصالحه هذا الدفع باتجاه
المصالحه وطي صفحه الماضي هل كان لروسيا
اي دور
فيه لم نقل بشكل مباشر فان التقارب بين
تركيا وروسيا ادى لعب دورا غير مباشر في
تحقيق التقارب بين تركيا والعراق ومع
الاسف عدم التواصل
والسياسه متردده من قبل دول الغرب زادت من
الوضع الفوضوي في المنطقه وان وان السياسه
الحازمه لروسيا وتدخلها ورغم ان
ذلك
ليس امرا مقبولا من قبل كل دول
المنطقه بكل جوانبها الا ان هذا التدخل
وهذه السياسه
الحازمه من قبل روسيا اثرت على علاقات
تركيا مع الدول المجاوره ونحن نعلم ان
روسيا بدات مؤخرا بالابتعاد عن الوجهه
النظر الايرانيه وبالتالي فان هذا النوع
من الفتور في العلاقات بين روسيا
وايران الاقتراب روسيا من تركيا من العراق
من روسيا ادى كان له دور كبير فيما يتعلق
ب فتور علاقه العراق
ب بايران وتعزيز تقاربها مع دوله تركيا
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بالتاكيد ان الموقف
الروسي لعب دورا كبيرا في هذا ام سيد
دكتور الشمري يعني سمعت م قيل بخصوص ربما
هذه العلاقات الجديده او افاق التقارب
الجديد في بين دول المنطقه هنا هنا اسال
فعلا ان كانت ايران ستنظر بعين الرضا الى
هذه المصالحه الى هذا
التقارب قد لا اكن معنيا
او لما ستطرحه ايران بالتحديد لكن بتصوري
ان يعني الاندفاع نحو هذا الموضوع يعني من
وجهه نظري كعراقي لابد ان ينطلق على اساس
المصلحه العراقيه نحن هنا لا ننظر ان
وافقت ايران او لم توافق او نظرت بقلق او
لم تنظر هنا نحدد يعني مصلحتنا العراقيه
الاهم هو ان يكون هناك رضا وقبول داخلي
لطبيعه هذه الزياره وانا اعتقد ان ما تحقق
على مستوى هذه الزياره من قرار سحب القوات
التركيه وايضا اداره ملف المياه بشكل
مشترك واعاده العلاقات الاقتصاديه ايران
انا اعتقد انها الان منخرط بتسويه على
مستوى المنطقه ولذلك لا يمكن لها وهي
تمتلك علاقات استراتيجيه مع تركيا لا يمكن
لها باي حال من الاحوال ان تدفع او حتى
هكذا ارى يعني من وجهه نظر تحليليه لا
يمكن لها ان
يعني ان تعود مره اخرى الى منطق الصراعات
او ترى بالعراق يعني ساحه لل التصارع ما
بين بغداد من جهه وانقره من جهه اخرى مره
اخرى اؤكد بان المصلحه العراقيه هي من
تحدد القبول وليس القبول الايراني للتحرك
العراقي س سيد اتمان يعني سياسيا هل هناك
مقابل يفترض ان يدفعه هذا الطرف وذاك
لانجاح هذه
المصالحه
افهم السؤال بالضبط ما يعني سالت ان كان
المطلوب من تركيا ومن العراق ان يكون هناك
مقابل متبادل حتى تنجح هذه
المصالحه على الارض
التطورات في المستقبل وما سيحصل من احداث
في المستقبل ستؤثر على الارجح على موقف
هذه الدول الثلاث فنحن نعلم ان تركيا
وايران دولتان مهمتان في المنطقه
وان التاكيد العراقي على البعد ما بين
الحكومات والعلاقات ما بين الحكمات
سيزيد التدخل الايراني في الشؤون العراق
نحن نعلم ان ايران تحاول ان تستفيد او
تستغل السياسات الطائفيه لتامين ام
سيدمان انا اسف ربما الفكره الفكره وصلت
وصلت ولو مشز اشكرك سيد مح الدين اتمان
الباحث في مركز الدراسات السياسيه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه سيتا من انقرا
واشكر الدكتور احسن الشمري رئيس مركز
التفكير السياسي من بغداد نهايه هذه حقه
من برنامج مرا الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في مراء خبر جديد دمتم
[موسيقى]
بخير